Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Bonjour.
Je me présente, je fais des dessins.
Je vais vous le montrer -
j’ai tout ce qu’il faut là.
Comment j’ai commencé ?
J’ai raté mes études.
J'ai parlé très tard, j'ai marché très
tard et mes parents étaient inquiets.
Ils pensaient que j’avais un problème.
Un jour, mon père m’a tendu un crayon.
Ce qui est drôle, c’est que j’ai cru
que je m’appuyais sur quelque chose.
C’étaient mes premiers pas.
C’est pour vous dire que
des fois, le hasard -
comme le thème, c’est l’existence -
il y a des hasards qui font
qu’il y a des mains tendues.
Là, c’est une main tendue avec un crayon.
Puis, il y a ce qu’on en fait.
Je vais vous raconter un peu
l’existence de quelqu’un
qui essaie de raconter
et de séduire par des dessins.
Je vais vous montrer
un petit poisson bulle.
Le petit poisson bulle,
il dessine, et il dessine
à 12 000 mètres sous l’eau.
C’est pour faire venir la femelle.
Il a une petite arête sur le ventre.
Là, il est en train de nettoyer,
de faire son petit ménage.
Comme nous, quand
on est avec la page blanche,
et qu’avec la gomme,
on enlève les petites impuretés,
lui, il prépare le terrain parce
qu’il a envie de faire un dessin
pour que la femelle poisson bulle arrive.
Le petit poisson bulle,
Il fait son dessin.
Il nettoie, il enlève
les petits coquillages
qui ne sont pas bien pour sa page blanche.
Donc il va faire une rosace
encore plus belle -
vous allez le voir -
que la rosace de Notre-Dame.
On a découvert ça il y a une vingtaine
d’années dans les fonds marins.
Il fait des dessins remarquables.
Ce qui est extraordinaire, c’est
qu’une fois que son dessin est terminé,
la femelle arrive :
« Oh, c’est beau, c’est joli ! »
Et puis crac !
(Rires)
Et ça, c’est étonnant
parce que, finalement,
qu’est-ce qu’on fait d’autre
quand on fait une poésie, une chanson,
quand on fait un exposé,
quand on fait une lettre, un message ?
Voilà, à la fin, ça se fait comme ça.
Comment on trouve une idée de dessin ?
Moi, je lis le journal, j’adore
la télévision, j’adore les infos,
ça se passe dans le cerveau,
je ne sais pas où, mais ça se passe là.
Au départ, très important -
Je pense que ça passe aussi par l’œil.
Quand on regarde par là, on dit : « Ah ! »
Quand on cherche une idée, on regarde
la lumière, je ne sais pas pourquoi
ça nous aide à trouver.
Je vous le dis parce que quand on cherche
sur un plan, on est perdu.
« L’Avenue Charles de Gaulle ?
Je l’ai su. »
Et on regarde par là alors que...
Bon, pas grave.
Puis ça passe par le cœur - très bien.
Il faut que quand on exprime
une opinion, ça passe par le cœur.
Dire : « Ça, j’y crois. »
Vous allez voir que dans ma vie,
j’ai rencontré pas mal
de journalistes au Monde,
de directeurs, de rédacteurs en chef.
Il faut que ça passe par le cœur,
mais aussi par les tripes,
parce qu’à un moment,
il y a un côté (Toque sur le pupitre)
« Je veux le faire. »
Ça s’appelle une opinion
à laquelle on tient.
On peut se tromper,
mais c’est une opinion.
Là, on est 600.
S’il y en a 599
qui pensent quelque chose -
Je vais beaucoup dans les écoles
et je leur dis :
« S’il y en a un qui pense différemment,
il faut l’écouter. »
Je dis aux enfants :
« Ne vous moquez pas de lui.
C’est peut-être génial, ou pas, ce n’est
pas grave, mais on ne va pas se moquer. »
Donc les tripes, c’est très important.
Ensuite, « Le journal me parle »,
et ça, c’est vrai.
« Ma page blanche me parle », c’est vrai,
« Mon crayon me parle », aussi.
J’avais eu un copain
brésilien qui avait dessiné -
J’étais avec lui à Rio,
il dessinait pour O Globo, le journal.
On voit arriver le nouveau pape.
À l’époque, c’était Benoît XVI.
Il commence à dessiner puis il dessine le
pape, impeccable - en aquarelle en plus.
La télé était là.
J’étais dans son journal.
Il dessine le pape Benoît XVI,
un peu comme ça.
La tunique blanche, tout ça.
Il commence à faire un brassard.
Je m’approche : « Tu fais quoi, là ? »
Il me dit : « Laisse. »
Et il fait un brassard rouge
avec un rond blanc avec une croix gammée.
Je lui dis : « Attends, Chico, » -
il s’appelle Chico -
Tu es en train de...
- Il est allemand.
- Il est allemand, D’accord, mais enfin...
C’est un raccourci.
- Laisse penser ton crayon. »
Je vous le dis parce que des fois,
le crayon, il dit des choses,
des fois il a raison, des fois il a tort.
Donc il faut écouter son crayon.
Tout le monde me parle.
Même quand je scanne mon dessin
et que je le mets sur l’écran,
l’écran, il me dit encore quelque chose.
Quand c’est sur mon écran et que
je le reprends chez moi, dans mon iPhone,
je le vois encore différemment.
Il faut toujours avoir un œil neuf
et se faire accompagner
de l’œil neuf d’un copain, d’une sœur,
d’une cousine, d’un prof.
Et donc à la fin - là,
c’est une idée pas très claire -
d’habitude, j’essaye de faire
des idées un peu plus claires.
Il faut avoir des références au début.
Moi, j’ai recopié Hergé, j’ai adoré Hergé.
Par exemple. Sarko, j’ai fait ça en 2012.
Je l’appelais « Racaille le rouge »
d’ailleurs à l’époque.
(Rires)
Regardez le petit Milou,
il est transformé comme ça.
Même à l’époque, j’avais fait
Strauss-Kahn en vert, évidemment.
Il ne comprend rien :
« On a marché sur les burnes ? »
Bon, ça, c’est autre chose.
Le boulot du dessinateur,
c’est de toujours -
Tiens, on va faire -
Comme personne ne suivait Hollande en 2011
au Mali et que les Européens disaient :
« Oui oui, on est avec toi.
Je te dirais même plus, on est avec toi. »
En fait, il était tout seul.
Il est très bien,
il me rappelle « Tintin au Congo ».
Et ça, ça me permet
de continuer le travail
quand il n’écoute pas
les gens qui lui parlent.
On se dit : « On va faire Tournesol. »
Puis on le dessine en Superman,
on le dessine en Bécassine.
Hollande, c’était un bon client ;
je lui dois beaucoup, lui aussi.
En Captain America, il n’était pas très
crédible, mais ce n’est pas grave.
Je l’aimais bien en Gaston Lagaffe,
c’était bien.
En schtroumpf, mais je préférais l’autre ;
l’autre, c’est le vrai schtroumpf.
Lui, c’est l’inventeur du schtroumpf,
bien avant Hollande.
Et à la fin, en petit bonhomme de Sempé.
Je trouve qu’il y a
quelque chose chez lui.
C’est pour vous dire à quel point,
en dessin, on discute avec la page.
C’est-à-dire que quand je fais mon
De Gaulle comme ça, je fais mon Tintin.
Parce que j’aime Tintin.
Et à la fin, je fais
un petit Sarko comme ça.
Ça me permet de faire un dialogue
avec tous ces personnages.
En 1983, j’avais deux dessinateurs
références que j’adorais :
Reiser qui est un immense
dessinateur de Charlie Hebdo,
qui faisait un personnage
qui s’appelait Gros Dégueulasse.
Il était toujours en slip.
La même année, Hergé était au paradis.
Et du coup, j’ai réutilisé
la bulle des Tintin
dans la bouche de mon
petit gros dégueulasse.
« Bordel de merde », bien sûr
Tintin ne sait pas ce que ça veut dire.
Je les ai mis ensemble.
Pour vous dire à quel point -
C’était à la une du monde,
le rédacteur en chef me dit « C’est bien,
tu rends hommage à Reiser et à Hergé.
Mais c’est quoi ça ?
C’est quoi ce truc-là ? »
Et encore, à l’époque, je n’avais
droit qu’au noir et blanc,
sinon j’aurais mis du jaune, vous voyez ?
(Rires)
Le boulot du dessinateur.
J’ai imaginé aujourd’hui,
si Hergé revenait sur Terre,
peut-être qu’il rendrait hommage
aux Ukrainiens, aux Ukrainiennes ?
La petite Castafiore ferait
des selfies du matin au soir.
C’est une suite, comme ça ;
il ferait une petite Greta.
Il faut dire que c’est
un bon client celle-là aussi :
elle fait la gueule tout le temps,
c’est bien.
Un petit personnage que j’ai inventé
avec les Chinois au moment du début -
Une petite chauve-souris, évidemment.
Un pangolin, bien sûr.
Le petit Zorino, on pourrait
faire une aventure de Tintin
défenseur des forêts, avec les forêts
qui sont dévastées en Amérique latine.
L’Amérique latine qu’on n’écoute
pas assez en ce moment.
Je reviens du Costa Rica - j’étais
deux, trois jours au Costa Rica.
On a plein de choses à apprendre.
Ils apprennent à sourire dans un pays où -
L’autre jour, j’étais dans une brasserie
à San José au Costa Rica.
La fille qui était avec moi demande -
je vous le dis car c’est
un truc incroyable sur l’empathie -
je ne sais pas comment
on parle en espagnol, mais elle dit :
« Dos café, mi amor. »
Je dis : « Vous connaissez le barman ?
- Non, mais les cafés
viendront plus facilement.
- Oh, c’est bien ça. »
(Rires)
Je vous le dis, si vous allez
à Paris et que vous dites :
« Deux cafés, mon amour »,
ça peut basculer, je vous le dis -
je crois que je lui ai rendu service.
Ça, c’est Tintin -
On imagine Tintin dans « Les cigares du
pharaon » accueillant des migrants
sortant d'un petit sarcophage.
J’adore ce boulot de dessinateur
où on dialogue -
Quand il y a eu les 80 ans
du capitaine Haddock,
on ne se défaisait pas du Covid,
je me suis dit : « Oh, on va faire
le petit pansement qui reste collé. »
Évidemment, vous avez compris :
Racaille le rouge.
Très important, les photos.
Quand je vois quelqu’un,
vous n’imaginez pas à quel point cette
personne me parle par ses mots, bien sûr,
mais à la fois par son attitude.
Et une main comme ça.
C’est une photo que j’ai piquée
dans le Monde.
Un gars qui parle comme ça,
moi, ça me rappelle l’école.
« Tu vas voir ta gueule
à la récré, toi ! »
Et donc, du coup, le dessin, il est fait.
C’est à dire que je n’ai plus qu’à
le dessiner, ça vient tout seul,
il n’y a qu’à laisser faire le crayon.
J’ai compris la main, ça me
rappelle ce que j’ai vécu à l’école.
Et le dessin, il est fait.
C’est très très intéressant de voir
à quel point il faut se laisser aller
à la spontanéité du cœur, des tripes,
et se dire :
« Je vais le faire quand même. »
Évidemment, lui, je l’ai fait en Madame
de Fontenay, je l’ai fait en tout.
Je lui dois un argent fou à celui-là -
enfin, ça, c’est autre chose.
Très important, le rôle
des femmes en politique.
« Toi, faire de la politique ? Mais tu ne
sais même pas faire une fausse facture. »
C’est un truc tout bête -
aucun rapport avec lui.
Quoique.
Ensuite, les nouveaux.
L’autre qui se prenait pour Jupiter
et qui ressemble à Gulliver
avec les Gilets jaunes.
Elle, très bien.
Très bonne cliente, madame Borne.
Voilà une Première ministre
qui s’occupe du 49.3.
Très bien, très bien.
Lui qui nous conseillait
de rester six à table
quand on avait les masques.
Du coup, la Cène...
Jésus-Christ, tout ça,
on fait les apôtres.
Je ne sais pas qui est Judas,
mais il y a les apôtres.
Ensuite, un dessin très vieux,
de 81, où j’avais fait -
Le dessin, il faut apprendre à penser que,
quand on dessine, tout est casse-gueule.
Je me souviens, on est en 81.
Qu’est-ce que je dis dans mon dessin,
dans le Monde ?
« Prix, chômage, santé du président. »
J’avais appris que le Président
était malade en 81.
Donc j’ai fait Mitterrand.
Le directeur me dit :
« Mais c’est quoi votre truc, là ?
On a imprimé ça en 1e édition,
mais ça ne va pas ? »
Donc en 2e édition,
il a disparu, Mitterrand.
Or, j'avais un scoop.
Mais un dessinateur
ne peut pas être porteur d’un scoop.
« Mais non, lui, il n’est pas capable. »
Donc je dessine mes présidents.
J’ai fait Giscard, j’ai fait Mitterrand,
j’ai fait Pompidou, j’ai fait Chirac.
De Gaulle était très facile.
Le dernier que je fais souvent
en culottes courtes, ça lui va bien.
Quand il est mort, Mitterrand -
Très important,
le contact avec la rédaction en chef,
quand on dessine Mitterrand.
On est dans les années 78-80.
Il meurt en 96.
Mais avant, je n’avais pas le droit
de dessiner la verrue de Mitterrand.
« Tu te rends compte ? Mitterrand,
tu ne vas pas dessiner une verrue.
- Mais vous ne l’avez pas vue ?
Il a une verrue. »
Pendant plusieurs mois,
j’ai été interdit de verrue,
mais après je l’ai remise.
Et quand il est mort -
Notre première langue à nous,
c’est l’image.
Depuis, je me suis dit :
« On va aller dans les écoles,
on va réapprendre ce qu’est un dessin. »
On va réapprendre grâce au prof de dessin,
on va réapprendre ce qu’est une opinion.
« Tu veux dire ça ?
Je ne suis pas forcément d’accord,
mais pas grave, on va la partager. »
Là, c’est à Gaza avec une dessinatrice
qui s’appelle Omaya,
pas du tout d’accord avec moi.
Ce n’est pas grave, on dialogue -
elle était du Hamas - et donc on dialogue.
Partout où je suis allé,
toujours avec l’idée
qu’on va essayer de réinventer un dialogue
entre les Israéliens et les Palestiniens.
Ça a été déterminant dans ma vie.
J’ai imaginé un petit Israélien et un
petit Palestinien sur une balançoire.
Mon boulot de dessinateur, c’est aussi
d’essayer d’inventer des dialogues,
même avec un photographe.
Ce photographe, c’est Reza,
un immense photographe iranien
qui a connu la prison en Iran.
C’est une expo qui a commencé
il y a deux jours au musée de l’Homme
où on rassemble à la fois
des dessins et des photos de Reza.
Là encore, il y a une part d’indécence
dans le boulot d’un artiste,
une part d’indécence
dans le boulot d’un dessinateur
venant voir un photographe :
« On se connaît depuis quinze ans.
Est-ce que on pourrait imaginer -
- Oui, vas-y, rentre dans mes photos.
- Ben, pourquoi pas ? »
Regardez la petite plante verte.
Ce dessin que j’avais dû faire
dans les années 80 en N&B,
j’ai rajouté la même couleur verte
dans les petits continents
qui sont dans [l’arbre].
Et ça, c’est Reza qui nous montre
ses rapports avec ses amis iraniens.
Ça, c’est une Iranienne
que j’ai mélangée avec un dessin
parce que l’arme de la vidéo, c’est
une arme qui paraît silencieuse,
mais qui est peut-être
plus dangereuse qu’un pistolet.
J’essaie de proposer une conversation
avec des dessinateurs.
Par exemple, regardez ce photographe
qui fait cette photo
d’un immense -
Il y a une émotion incroyable
avec ce militaire américain
qui est en Afghanistan et qui se demande
s’il va rester ou pas rester.
Moi, à ce moment-là,
sans connaître cette photo,
je fais ce dessin-là à la une du Monde,
avec ce militaire sans tête.
Et finalement, est-ce que dans le visage
incroyable dans la photo de Reza,
on n’y trouve pas déjà un début
de réponse avec ces images ?
C’est un mariage que nous inventons.
Il y a bien entendu
le travail au jour le jour.
Je vous ai parlé des réseaux sociaux.
Des fois c’est dangereux,
et des fois, quand des femmes sont
maltraitées par des voltigeurs à Téhéran,
heureusement qu’il y a
les réseaux sociaux.
Ce qui fait que je la fais
comme si elle était un portable.
On a connu le drame de cette jeune fille
qui avait osé montrer ses cheveux.
Ça, c'est le boulot du dessinateur
de raconter, de dénoncer.
Je suis allé en Iran plusieurs fois.
La dernière fois pour essayer
de libérer un dessinateur qui avait osé -
je vous le dis, quand on -
C’est incroyable !
Il avait osé dessiner l’ayatollah
Khomeiny en footballeur.
Ce n’était pas un truc très -
Six mois en taule quand même.
Il s’appelle Hassan Karimzadeh.
Hassan Karimzadeh, il reste à Téhéran.
Il est opposant,
mais il veut rester à Téhéran.
L’intérêt,
c’est de défendre les journalistes
et de prendre un stylo et de le mettre
dans la gueule d’un crocodile
qui est pour moi
l’exemple de la dictature.
Faire un dessin,
quand on dit : « Bon, ça urge. »
Je ne suis pas un spécialiste
de l’écologie, mais j’écoute.
Les journalistes,
c’est eux qui m’ont formé,
c’est eux qui m’ont dit :
« Écoute, prends des notes,
il faut faire un appel, ça urge. »
Je fais mon dessin, et après, je me dis :
« L’appel ! Je vais faire un porte-voix.
Et dans le porte-voix,
je vais faire la mappemonde.
Et je vais faire de l’eau qui coule. »
Rien ne vient naturellement,
c’est comme une phrase.
Quand on fait une phrase,
il y a un verbe, une syntaxe, un article.
Moi, mon boulot, c’est de raccorder
une conversation avec des motifs,
des bouts de dessins.
Avec les lettres,
on fait des jeux de mots.
Là, ce sont des jeux de signes
qu’on rassemble.
Quand il y a eu le Covid,
j’ai imaginé que les soignants
à qui je voulais rendre hommage,
c’était un peu comme le Boléro de Ravel.
(Rythme du Boléro)
C’est comme un combat.
J’avais fait une Marianne -
Au début, j’avais fait une Marianne
avec les yeux baissés.
Au début, j’avais fait un mec
de mon âge, un peu gros, tout ça.
« Non non, je vais mettre Marianne. »
Après j’ai fait Marianne, les yeux baissés
comme si elle était dans les vapes.
Non, j’ai fait une Marianne
avec les yeux ouverts
pour qu’on puisse donner du positif
dans la douleur qu’on a connue
en janvier et février 2020.
Après, j’ai fait avec Gautier Capuçon
des couvertures de disques
pour rendre hommage à ces soignants
qui font un boulot formidable.
J'ai fait 53 expos dans les hôpitaux.
La semaine prochaine,
dans l’hôpital du Mans.
Je n’arrête pas ; j’étais à Maubeuge...
Je n’arrête pas,
Je peux vous dire
à quoi sert un dessinateur.
Je vais voir les directeurs
d’hôpitaux, je leur dis :
« Si vous voulez, j’ai 200 dessins
pour rendre hommage aux soignants. »
Je me suis rendu compte que quand je vais
voir les soignants, les ambulanciers,
ceux qui s’occupent d’intuber les gens,
les infirmières, les gens aux urgences,
ils avaient besoin qu’on les écoute.
Ces expos que je fais -
Il y avait un moment où on applaudissait
à 20 h, on ne le fait pus.
Je me suis rendu compte que dans les 53
hôpitaux où je suis allé jusqu’à présent,
c’est un applaudissement silencieux,
mais un applaudissement quand même.
Ils ont besoin -
Je l’ai appris à force d’y aller.
Maintenant je -
Je vais à l’hôpital de Béziers
dans pas longtemps.
Je me dis qu’ils ont besoin
qu’on leur dise merci.
Je pensais qu’ils le savaient.
Eh bien non, il faut leur redire.
Je trouve que, eux qui nous aident
et qui nous sauvent,
il faut les aider.
Évidemment, il y a la guerre en Ukraine.
J’ai utilisé les deux couleurs
de l’Ukraine,
j’ai utilisé des gens
qui essayent de partir.
J’ai revisité - je vous dis
que j’étais nul en géographie.
Je me dis : « L’Ukraine.
Il y a la Biélorussie,
la Russie, la Roumanie, la Moldavie.
Ah, mais ça ressemble à une colombe. »
Donc j’ai inventé une colombe.
Parce que ça se terminera par une colombe,
évidemment, bien entendu.
L’empathie, c’est d’essayer
de se mettre à la place de l’autre.
J’aime cette petite Ukrainienne qui dit :
« J’ai de la pitié pour les Russes,
ils ont tué leurs semblables. »
Ça me plaît parce que c’est le début
d’une conversation avec les deux.
Le rôle d’Internet : vous avez compris, il
y a des choses formidables avec Internet,
et il y a le problème qu’on vit.
Le chat, des fois, joue avec la souris.
La souris, elle se fait
bouffer par le chat
car des fois on n’y arrive plus, comme
on l’a vu au moment de la crise sanitaire.
Il y a eu des fake news tout le temps.
Il y a des gens qui font croire qu’avec
tel produit, on va sauver les gens.
Pour terminer là-dessus :
qui est l’inventeur des réseaux sociaux ?
Eh bien, c’est Richelieu.
Parce que Richelieu -
j’aime beaucoup ce tableau
de Philippe de Champaigne ;
je l’ai dessiné comme ça -
était connu pour avoir dit
cette phrase incroyable :
« Qu’on me donne dix lignes écrites
de la main du plus honnête homme
et j’y trouverai
de quoi le faire pendre. »
C’est un peu ce qui guette évidemment
les dessinateurs, les journalistes,
mais ce qui nous guette, nous,
citoyens de la planète,
où on essaye de partager des opinions,
dans un monde qui est un
petit peu réduit en ce moment.
Si on ne se laisse pas faire,
on gagnera cette bataille contre
les procureurs des réseaux sociaux.
Mais en attendant,
on va essayer de se battre
pour ne pas écouter
cette maxime de Richelieu :
« Qu’on me donne dix lignes écrites
de la main du plus honnête homme,
j’y trouverai de quoi le faire pendre. »
Merci beaucoup et à bientôt.
(Applaudissements)